our group at MIT is studying semi
autonomous vehicles now that includes
both inward-facing census for driver
state sensing and outward-facing sensors
for scene perception and the control
planning motion planning tasks now today
we'll look at the second part of that at
the perception and the control of the
vehicle on the dashboard of the Tesla
there's a Jetson tx2 with a camera
sitting on top of it
we have a neural network and two end
running on the Jetson
that's detecting the forward roadway
taking it a sequence of images and
producing steering commands we also have
here a Tesla that has a perception
control system on it in the form of
autopilot it's using a monocular camera
this is the hardware version one it's
making decisions based on this single
video stream producing steering commands
and we'll look at two systems arguing
today auto pilot arguing against a
neural network and we'll see what comes
out in this concept Tesla autopilot is
the primary AI system and the entire
neural network is the secondary AI
system and the disagreement between the
two is used to detect challenging
situations and seek human drivers
supervision it is important to clarify
that this is not a criticism of auto
pilot of the two it is by far the
superior perception control system the
question is whether the argument between
the two systems can create transparency
that leverage the human driver as a
supervisor of challenging driving
scenarios scenarios that may have not
otherwise been caught by auto pilot
alone this is a general framework for
supervision of blackbox AI systems that
we hope can help save human lives in the
paper accompanying this video we show
that we can predict driver initiate
disengagement of autopilot with a simple
threshold on the disagreement of
steering decisions we believe this is a
very surprising and powerful result that
hopefully may be useful for human
supervision of any kind of AI system
that operates in the real world and
makes decisions where errors may result
in loss of human life
a quick note that we use the intensity
of red color on the disagreement
detected text as the visualization of
disagreement magnitude in retrospect
this is not an effective visualization
because visually it looks like the two
systems are constantly disagreeing they
are not the intent of the on-road demo
is to show successful real-time
operation of the arguments framework the
paper that goes along with this approach
on the other hand is where we show the
predictive power of this approach on
large-scale naturalistic data
inside the car we have a screen over the
center stack and a Jetson tx2 with a
camera on top of it the camera is
feeding a video stream into the Jetson
Island Jetson is a neural network that's
predicting the steering command taking
an end to end the video stream from the
forward roadway and as an output for the
neural network giving a steering command
that's being shown as pink on this
display the pink line is the steering
suggested by the neural network cyan
line is the steering of the car of the
Tesla that we're getting from the can
bus so when I moved the steering wheel
around we see that live in real-time
mapped on this graphic here showing in
cyan the steering position of the car
and up top is whenever the to disagree
significantly the disagreement detected
red sign appears showing that there's a
disagreement and I'll demonstrate that
on-road we're now driving on the highway
with the Tesla being controlled by
autopilot and the Jetson tx2 on the
dashboard with a camera plugged in has a
neural network running on it and to end
and the inputs of the neural network is
a sequence of images and the output of
steering commands now there's 2
perception control systems working here
one is autopilot the other one is an
end-to-end neural network both the
steering commands from both are being
visualized on the center stack here in
pink is the output from the neural
network and cyan is the output from
autopilot and whenever there is some
disagreement or a lot of disagreement up
on top there's a disagreement detected
text that becomes more intensely red the
greater the disagreement at the bottom
of the screen is the input to the neural
network that is a sequence of images
that are subtracted from each other
capturing the temporal dynamics of the
scene
all right so why is this interesting
there is two perception control systems
- AI systems taking in the external
world using a monocular camera and
making a prediction making steering
commands to control the vehicle now
whenever those two systems disagree
that's interesting for many reasons one
the disagreement is an indicator that
from a visual perspective from a
perception perspective the situation is
challenging for those systems therefore
you might want to bring the drivers
attention to the situation so they take
control back from the vehicle it's also
interesting for validating systems so if
you propose a new perception control
system you can imagine putting it into a
car to go along with autopilot or with
other similar systems to see how well
that new system works with autopilot 1in
disagrees when it doesn't and the
disagreement from the computer vision
aspect is also really interesting for
detecting edge cases so the challenge
you think about driving or for building
autonomous vehicles is that most of
driving is really boring the interesting
bits happen rarely so one of the ways to
detect those interesting bits the edge
cases is to look at the disagreement
between these perception systems to look
at cases when the two perception systems
diverge and therefore they struggle with
that situation finally when the driver
is controlling and takes control of the
vehicle which I am doing now and when my
steering decisions my turning of the
steering wheel is such that the neural
network disagrees it perhaps means that
I am either distracted or the situation
is visually challenging therefore I
should pay extra attention so it makes
sense for the system to warn you about
that situation
now the interesting thing about Tesla
and the autopilot system is that if we
instrument a lot of these vehicles as we
have we've instrumented 20 Tesla's as
part of the MIT autonomous vehicle study
and are collecting month
month after month year after year now
data video in and video out we can use
that data to train better systems to
Train perception systems control motion
planning and the end-to-end network that
we're showing today we have the
large-scale data to train the the
learning based perception and control
algorithms now an important thing to
mention is that these systems were
designed to work on the highway at
highway speeds
so the kind of disagreement is trained
to detect is disagreement between
autopilot and the neural network in
highway situations so the visual
characteristics of lane markings
deteriorating or construction zones and
so on now the details and if you're
interested in more can be found in a
paper titled arguing machines
you